foreign
you commented and we read hello
everybody and welcome to another video
after the positive feedback on the first
massacre video and the demand for a
second one
it was a no-brainer to pass the bill on
anime massacre part
two we tried to make this sensitive
subject a bit of fun and sometimes
people forget that these folks who are
getting cut in half are actually
fictional characters okay so with that
in mind
please give a like and have an eye out
on the subscriber notification bell
while we narrate this
not so pg-13 list
castlevania what goes around comes
around
this sentence marked the state of being
screwed beyond redemption and the
begging of the end for the foolish folks
of valencia who instead of apologizing
through a celebration on the same day a
crazy boomer dressed like the pope
killed the wife of count dracula so in
turn poor dracula responded by
unleashing the night army which looked
like a hybrid of a bat and a dragon
these ugly ass beasts took the small
town in a minute tearing through
pedestrians like a knife through butter
and to then go on to the entire country
for the endless lifetime of hate they
put in our weird uncle heart
devil man crybaby orgy of death
oh boy where to begin i mean seriously i
don't know where to begin
the scene was so overwhelming i don't
even know if the editor can show the
footage of the bloodbath that actually
went down
the whole thing went from a sick orgy
party that i'd like to be a part of i
mean
i'm not gonna lie don't judge me i mean
i can feel some of you have some weird
fantasies
i just want some sabbath action in my
boring life now i'm joking i'm joking
seriously though
this party went from 100 to 1 million
and it was all because of that blonde
fuckboy who went on a murdering rampage
for the devils to possess
dem wild animals and oh boy his plan
worked
one minute there was a hot blonde with
nice off by next minute you have a huge
bird with humongous off by
and yes there is more a demon with two
mouths
made from a girl pair dude not gonna cap
i'm reading this [ __ ] it's off
the whole thing ended with the main man
getting possessed by a powerful devil
who in turn went on a rampage
and killed all the other devils damn
what a journey that was
what began as a cave exploring mission
ended in a time travel mission when a
while doki saka the time turner appeared
and flung the dynamic duo dora and ushio
into the past to show them the origin of
the beast's spear
there they meet with jimey as well as
her family who are planning to make a
holy sword that can defeat the powerful
monster hakumen
no mono this sword's also supposed to be
the ticket for the jime family to get
back in the palace
however unbeknown to them the weird
homicidal cousin of the nine-tailed fox
is waiting there
and he's pissed by the thought of people
making holy swords to defeat him
hence it's no surprise that this
encounter ended pretty bad if i dare say
so myself
i tried to count how many died and from
the looks of it a lot kicked the bucket
including the parents over traumatized
sweat jamie
[Applause]
is trusting in their ability to deliver
three things
awesome action scenes sick ost
hard hit deaths and episode 51 delivered
all of that in what can only be
described as a gang flex
the phantom troops swept through york
new city like a locust reaping every
breathing creature in their way
while classical opera music plays in the
background however what took the scene
from pretty cool
to epic is their leader who already
killed two assassins
one off cam and the second also off-cam
too but it was evident he went john wick
mode on his touchy with almost a dozen
bends sticking out of the lifeless body
after completely finishing them he stood
high up and raised his hands towards the
sky
and started moving them like a maestro
conducting an orchestra of death and
[Music]
sadness
oh
[Music]
death from the sky now here's some
context behind this massacre
15 years after heaven's fall the
princess of mars travels to earth on a
diplomatic mission now all's going well
for the earth people until some
terrorists attack the motorcade of the
martian delegation with guided missiles
so although it initially appears that
the limousine carrying the princess
avoided the attack
the terrorists successfully hit the
limousine with a second volley and it's
believed that the princess is killed
in retaliation the verse orbital knights
launch an all-out assault on earth via
the descent of their landing castles
from earth orbit and launching missiles
which destroy undersea cables
geostationary communication satellites
major cities and needless to say any
life form in the vicinity
that time i got reincarnated as a slime
birth of a demon lord now this entry has
not one but
two massacres the first ones in episode
six when the humans attacked rimuru city
with a great force that made them look
like mega deckheads
which is a testament to their might in
this episode however
fast forward four episodes and the
tables have turned as the magic barrier
that weakens the monsters breaks
giving them their full power back and
taking some well-earned revenge on the
soldiers
on the other hand rumuru who is and will
always be the mvp
ends episode 10 by transcending from a
powerful monster
to a freaking demon lord to revive the
fallen citizens of tempest
helping him to achieve that is 10 000
unaware soldier souls who as he put it
should be honoured for being part of his
[Applause]
evolution
one man army looking down at an army
while an ominous soundtrack plays in the
background didn't look any cooler than
this before
the one-man army took the stage with all
his glory clapping ninja cheeks by the
second
mother art showed how a real uchiha in
his prime should be like
throwing the alliance soldiers like a
ragdoll all over the place
and if that wasn't enough the guy woke
his rinigan and threw a freaking
meteorite
which is a testament for his strength
than being a tryhard however what truly
got me
aka triggered me in this violent art
piece is the lack of blood
from people being stabbed and burnt to
people being utterly crushed
and before we continue to the next scene
can we have f in the chat for that one
guy who was hit
so hard his upper body went in the
ground
end of evangelion the third impact how
can i describe this
no i mean seriously how can i describe
it death was all over the place
with a giant naked lady hoovering
everyone's souls and turning them into
orange juice and shinji sad existence on
the camera
too much was going on that i don't even
know how to describe it let alone the
whole series
whenever someone asks me about what
evangelion's all about i send them a
video of alex jones explains evangelion
to joe rogan and after this video ends
i'd advise you to watch it
mobile suit gundam the colony drop
massacre
the narrator of the anime described this
massacre the best so i'll be
paraphrasing
here we go universal century double 07.9
january 10th a big space colony bigger
than joe mama
leaves its point and enters in a
free-fall trajectory towards earth
its estimated point of impact was in
north america which harbors the earth
federal generation hq beneath it
a fleet tries to destroy the colony but
fails big time
on january 15th the ship enters earth's
orbit
january 16th the colony split into three
pieces
crashing in east asia australia and
canada
killing half of the planet population
and putting the other half in a whole
state
yep this definitely belongs on this list
[Applause]
attack on titan finale declaration of
war
willie tiber visited mali and was making
his declaration of war to paradise
island
just then aaron turns into a titan and
eats willy destroying the building he
was in as well as the internet
holy hell did this moment blow up on
social media
chaos and murder run ramped inside the
city as innocent bystanders were kicking
the bucket
and titans falling left and right like
the ugly butterflies that they are
however to me the biggest moment from
this massacre and maybe the entire
series
was witnessing armin transform into the
new colossal titan
and destroying the borders once again
sending navy ships in the air like toys
if hell had a gate i'm sure the colossal
titan would be the gatekeeper
and that's about it i hope you enjoyed
the video we tried to make this touchy
subject as fun as possible and if you
think it was indeed a good time spent on
this video then why not drop the like
and give us the pleasure of having you
as a subscriber
so we can see you on the next one